so of course we're going to see this
Ridge develop even more over us the next
few days here especially tomorrow but
what happens is the jet stream acts like
a a jump rope when you make a big jump
on the Rope the bottom part of the Rope
makes a big dip and that's going to
allow that cold air look at this that
cold Arctic air behind that arctic cold
front to slam into the mid section of
the U.S and eventually throughout the
East Coast all the way down to portions
of Florida and the Deep South here's a
look right now where the cold air is at
these are your accurate wind chills now
notice the white colors here go deeper
and deeper and deeper and then cut
across the country that's what's going
to happen with that arctic cold front
along with blizzard conditions for the
northern plain states for the uh also
the Great Lakes region for those areas
there the Upper Midwest dealing with
some blizzard conditions there we're
checking on your airport delays I know
many of you are flying out no major
airport delays but that will change
tomorrow and I'll have that uh travel
forecast coming up clear skies for us
right now but look at the clouds they'll
be coming in from the West we'll see
those we think later on tomorrow but if
you're planning doing that morning walk
and Jog things look pretty good A little
chilly in the morning but after that
conditions will improve through the day
for tomorrow the temperatures will warm
up 40 degrees your forecast overnight
clear and cool now tomorrow we'll see
increased clouds 58 degrees or high for
tomorrow that puts us right near normal
for this time of year and then the
warming Trend begins again on Friday
look at that we're looking at 60s for
this week and then mid 60s for tips okay
mid 60s then with slight chances for
showers Wednesday and Thursday